popular portion along the Las Vegas
Strip will soon be fading away yeah that
shopping area just south of Harmon
recently bought by an investor as
Christian casarez reports the clock is
really ticking to get all the tenants
out
that was kind of on the slow side you
could tell this was uh
this was the next to go empty commercial
units along the Las Vegas Strip are
causing heads to turn from tourists
passing by we were four months ago it
was live it was thriving and now it's
all shut down vacant it's sad to see it
Go Katelyn Couture with the plug
recently closed she tells me Spectrum
group owned the property but was sold in
June to Texas billionaire Tillman
Fertitta his portfolio includes dining
entertainment the Houston Rockets and
the golden nuggets we recently
introduced like the nicotine Vapes which
was a huge thing over EDC so we were
really trying to grow this location
several employees say the shops began to
close their door shortly after the
property purchase was complete While
others were given more time we are
planning on moving this location so we
are we have retained all of our
employees we are we told them that you
know we're gonna find something for them
behind the retail row was the Travelodge
motel which construction workers tell us
the site was being prepped for
demolition before the end of the year I
think it's nice when you have you have
local people people you know reaching
out and you see tourism coming in and
you're supporting the mom-and-pop places
you have investors that come in they
wanna
put their money in and approve the area
and increase the value of their asset so
that's that's the natural order of
things in America
now Christian was told workers have
until the end of this month just to
vacate those units we did reach out to
the Spectrum group management and
Tillman for Titus company for comment
we're still waiting for information on
those future plans